[Music]
so the idea was that this coping and the
differences between optimists and
pessimists is how they cope with this
stress actually helped us explain why he
left the stress across time so as I said
a number of studies have been look I
have looked at coping differences going
up into some pessimists and and there
really are a number of very kind of
strategies that the users are really
very different optimists tend to seek
out information about what's happening
they actively cope and plan for trying
to make their plight better they try to
refrain in positive ways they seek
benefits and what's happened to them the
you tumor and the accept and in general
these things are more engagement coping
strategies they're actively dealing with
the stress that's confronting them
trying to reframe it trying to move on
with their lives pessimists on the other
hand suppress their thoughts about
what's happening to them they give up
the self distraction they avoid thinking
about the problem and these over denial
does not really happily - don't believe
that it's reality collectively you might
think being disengagement coping
techniques and the studies these
differences have been found repeatedly
in different studies you know over time
this really dozens and dozens and dozens
of studies showing these differences in
coping so optimist do cope differently
than pessimists and the difference seems
to engage optimists using engagement
coping techniques daily life focused
versatility toward disengagement pulling
back and not accepting the reality of
the situation
okay that was psychological being what
about physical well-being physical
health the optimist make a difference
there are optimists healthier than
pessimist again there's been a variety
of research done addressing this issue
people have looked at rehospitalization
at the different kinds of surgery they
looked at health of newborns in terms of
gestation period birth weights there's
been a lot of studies looking at disease
incidents which means you get a healthy
group of people at time one and you
study them across time you see who shows
new cases of that disease whatever it
might be down the road and they looked
at heart failure people instance of
stroke and other kinds of physical
disabilities there are also studies
looking at survival and mortality trying
to demonstrate if you get healthy people
at the beginning of a study track them
across 8 9 10 11 years and look and see
who dies is optimism predict you know
who lives and who dies down the road
well it turns out that there is in fact
very clear links I think between
optimism of physical health people
optimistic are healthier and they get
they just better outcomes so that
doesn't England again between optimism
and physical well-being even of all
things like mortality and survival
across time why does this happen
there really seem to be at least two
possibilities one possibility has to do
with differences in health promoting and
health damaging behavior the other
possibility is that there may be
different paths of physiological
reactions to optimists and pessimists
distress that might be linked to disease
and it might be a biological response
that causes them to obtain better health
outcomes that we see so let's consider
health behaviors first optimists tend to
engage proactively with things and that
proactive engagement with coping may
cause them promote health behaviors on
their part adopting more healthy
behaviors leads to better health the
other side of the coin pessimists they
tend to engage in these maladaptive
coping strategies disengagement
strategies
sure I could live a better lifestyle and
yet make my health is health behaviors
more healthy to me but the why should I
do that
is I'm going to
have a bad outcome anyway and then
because they engages these health
damaging behaviors their health suffers
of the consequence so it's really
evidence for both of these possibilities
compared to pessimists optimist exercise
more
they keep eat healthier foods adhere to
healthier diets and they will engage in
certain kinds of rehab programs when
they aren't factored printed with some
kind of illness outcome like
cardiovascular disease pessimists on the
other hand compared to optimists smoked
more and they drink more alcohol that
generally leave leave a less healthy
lifestyle so what about this other
pathway they talk to you about this
pathophysiology pathway so optimism as
we've been discussing and I described to
you really leads to less distress
let's distress is going to lead to less
blown biological reaction to the stress
you're experiencing less stress less
biological perturbation and that lower
biological response predicts better
health well there's evidence for these
biological pathways as well optimists
compared to pessimists I have been shown
to actually produce less stress hormones
when under stress they have higher
levels of antioxidants in their blood
that's a good thing to have they have
lower body mass index they have lower
markers of inflammation in their blood
they have lower rates of hypertension
lower cholesterol levels and if you look
at what happens to their arteries across
time they exhibit slower arterial
calcification and calcification in your
arteries is not a good things that have
happened - so it looks like in terms of
these bio pathophysiological pathways
the optimists look healthier to a
biological level level then do
pessimists
conclusions takeaway message first is
that optimism promotes better
psychological well-being why is this the
case it looks like least in part it has
to do with differences between between
the way optimists and pessimists cope
with the adversity that's confronting
them second conclusion optimism seems to
promote better physical health as well
why is that the case partly it has to do
with the differences between optimists
and pessimists in the health damaging
health learning behaviors that they
engage in part of it seems to do with
the impact of optimism the beneficial
effect it has on pathological pathways
[Music]